nous vous emmenons au népal un vieux
pays tout petit comme un quart de la
france est tiré le long du royaume
sublime de l'himalaya dont le karma et
le flegme sont étroitement lié au destin
de ces imposants voisin indien tibétains
et chinois
nous atterrissons à katmandou site est
stratégique
au delà des années hippies peuplé de
noirs les habitants de la vallée leur
civisme est un art comme tant d'autres
décliné depuis le moyen-âge avec la foi
et la désinvolture des peuples n'est
hindous qui jamais ne court après le
temps
cammas et bonjour bienvenue au royaume
du népal pour vous accueillir je suis à
katmandou sous le regard bienveillant du
bouddha au pied d'un des plus grands
stups à du monde ne suis pas de bois de
natte un des lieux spirituels très
prisée pour les tibétains en exil la
communauté est assez nombreuses ici au
népal je vous invite à un voyage
spirituel mais aussi assez cool vous
verrez qu à katmandou l'esprit pin n'est
pas mort et le stups à la bonne date et
un très bel endroit pour commencer ce
voyage parce qu'on y voit tout katmandou
ensuite nous irons faire un trek les
grandes randonnées bien connu au népal
pour l'instant je vous invite à
découvrir quatre mois nous on y va
au coeur de katmandou dans la vieille
ville indifférente aux voyageurs
hasardeuse et j'ai rencontré mike il
parle un peu le français et se propose
de m'orienter dans le dédale sans nombre
de ruelles et de place où les temples
porte le nom de la divinité honoré en ce
lieu
la croissance de katmandou s'est faite
par l'absorption d'un village par un
autre sans générer aucun urbanisme c'est
un peu le fruit
la vieille ville n'est pas très grande
aussi peut-on la découvrir ainsi en six
père d'enis flânant au fil des petits
marchés posés le long de ce qui fut la
principale artère commerciale de la cité
des petites bananes des mangues et
papayes keystone avec petit local et
pour combien on peut avoir un plat comme
sa commune roupies 1,5 environ 38 30
roupies 2
au cap vert pour toi c'est quoi la maman
la maman l'année l'étude teeb est allé
les voir le plein
mais bien sûr
alors
ah bon
l'agent me manquerait
aboya du piment la nasa
toute la vallée encaissée compte un
million d'habitants pour la plupart de
l'ethnie noir traditionnellement
commerçants et artisans ils ont acquis
une grande influence dans
l'administration du pays 150 copies
c'est cher les peintures et collages
dès que l'on croise un stade où il se
met à poser même si vous n'avez pas
d'appareil photo
les sâdhus sont des fidèles de shiva ou
de vishnou leur vie est devenue une
quête spirituelle erratique plus ou
moins authentiques des tâches et des
biens matériels
ils vivent de l'aumône autour des
temples nombreux adore bars quare le
palais et tous les temples qui compose
d'un bain skweres s'imbriquent autour de
trois places tous les édifices ont été
bâtis entre le 12e et le xviie siècle
selon la puissance des rois et l'intérêt
porté aux artistes pour le travail du
bois ou de la brique
katmandou est une ville attirante qui
grandit trop vite
aujourd'hui elle compte cinq cent mille
habitants ils sont un million dans toute
la vallée et la densité croissante pose
des problèmes dont la pollution de l'air
et de l'eau les collines alentours sont
étonnamment fertile alimentant en maïs
en riz et en blé la vallée même si le
mode de vie urbain gagne du terrain
ils en sont fiers les népalais de leurs
embouteillages mais il ne dure jamais
longtemps
c'est faire beaucoup
mèche nous emmène voir l'un des nombreux
trésors cachés du savoir-faire nepali
une fonderie en bronze anachronique
c'est dans le quartier de patan que sont
installés les fondeurs brûlant depuis
des siècles des figurines divine hindous
bouddhique tantrique sans modifier d'un
degré la chaleur infernale du four ni
les dangers des manipulations
bouillonnante
on retrouve sur les étals des marchés de
patan devant les temples ou dans les
échoppes brillante et spécialisés des
statuettes à tous les prix de 50 à 5000
roupies entre 5 et 500 francs
quand les chinois ont envahi le tibet
beaucoup de tibétains ont fui les
persécutions en trouvant refuge au népal
voisin
en 1960 la croix rouge a créé une vaste
fabrique de tapis au sud de patan qui
n'a plus rien en commun avec un camp de
réfugiés
mille femmes y travaillent qui ont monté
la plus grosse production du pays
une réussite florissante qui fait
largement vivre les 12000 tibétain en
exil de ce côté-ci de l'himalaya
les tapissière de zhao laquelle ont des
doigts d'or même si leur pelote sont de
pures laines de leur métier sont
exportés chaque année plus d'un million
et demi de mètres carrés de tapis qui
valent 500 millions de francs c'est la
plus rentable des manufactures du népal
dans un pays qui vit quasiment hors de
l'économie de marché
au milieu de la vallée coule une rivière
la bague mathy qui séparent les deux
villes de patan est de katmandou et qui
120 jusqu au gange
et un quartier qui s'appelle patane
c'est le prolongement de cartman ou b à
l'ouest ont très bien su slavia prague
bâti et pour moi c'est le plus joli
endroits de la vallée de katmandou c'est
sans doute pour ça qu verra m'avait
donné rendez vous ici à patane je vous
présente verra une française vivant à
katmandou ça fait longtemps que tu la
verras si la quatrième année oui
pourquoi es tu arrivé à katmandou dans
les années 70 tout n'aurait pas demandé
pourquoi et aujourd'hui peut-être un peu
plus d'un coup tu ça a commencé en fait
dans les années 70 je suis venu ici à 20
ans j'ai eu une petite fille qui est née
ici c'est vrai que j'ai eu toujours un
peu la nostalgie parce qu'à l'époque je
suis resté que six mois dans le pays et
je me suis toujours dit un jour je
reviendrai j'habiterai dans ce pays
parce que j'ai beaucoup voyagé c'est
vraiment le népal il ya quelque chose
qui s'est passé avec ce pays
il n'est ce pas de magie comme ça que
oui je crois qu'il ya plein de choses il
ya la gentillesse des gens il ya le fait
qu'on trouve une espèce de magie au
quotidien et une poésie qui n'existe
plus en france et qui pour moi est
indispensable et c'est avec mon jour où
j'ai décidé de revenir m'installer ici
j'ai absolument pas regretter j'ai je
suis vraiment ravi dhabi tma-20 génial
je crois qu'avec vers l'emv avoir un
guide génial merci beaucoup de la
semaine et beaucoup notre voyage au
népal
là c'est l'ancien palais royal de
pattani alors que ça c'est l'ancien
palais royal qui a été construit au
milieu du xviie siècle en 34 ici il ya
eu un gros tremblement de terre il ya
énormément de bâtiments qui sont
effondrés dont une partie du palais pas
mal de temps que le tour et heureusement
ça a été reconstruit tout à fait dans la
lignée de porcs travers l'architecturé
forte position des artisans fabuleux
l'ailé world
c'est vraiment des artisans de ce
magnifique ses sculptures sur bois super
grand artiste un tout petit peu de calme
avant d'en sortir
on dit un royaume le royaume du népal
c'est un petit monarchie
constitutionnelle maintenant c'est
intéressant car jusqu aux années
cinq ans il y en a toujours un qui est
toujours là mais c'est vrai qu'il n'a
plus le pouvoir absolu maintenant
puisque c'est un régime constitutionnel
quand tu viens de dire
mais il est toujours là il va c'est lui
qui officie à toutes les cérémonies
religieuses qui sont très importantes
ici parce que c'est quand même un
représentant des dieux pour le peuple
népalais donc c'est quelqu'un de très
important même s'il a pu vraiment un
rôle politique
c'est quelqu'un qui ceux qui vénèrent
énormément là chaque fois qu'il ya des
fêtes religieuses qui est vraiment très
souvent le cas ici le roi est là il
préside les faits tibet ni les gens
tatiana je crois qu'une fête religieuse
se prépare on commence à comment il
s'appelle celle là tu vas et des espèces
est arrivée la semaine de cesa sign
cette haine qui commence et c'est non
une phase qui est consacré la ds qui est
ce assez protégé de la vallée c'est des
gros fêtard des américains oui oui
française arrête les fêtes petites ou
grandes sont aussi nombreuses que les
divinités dans les hindous eux mêmes ne
connaissent pas le nombre elles ne sont
pas à date fixe car elles suivent le
calendrier lunaire qui datent les années
nepali on vit ici
57 ans avant la france
ok on a dealé combien cyclo-pousse 10
roupies soit allé un peu dans le
précédent tome elle donc c'est pas très
cher et en fait c'est pas un moyen de
locomotion que pour les touristes quoi
aller n'est pas allé aussi prennent ça
souvent oui le népal et les femmes
surtout utilise l'érection pour faire
leur shopping et n'inquiète pas les
femmes qui ont de l'argent bien sûr
donc c'est pas uniquement réservé aux
touristes si janet
il y à quelques rues commerçantes hamel
et le shopping est plus qu'intéressant
pour les immanquables bonnet de laine de
yak et les broderies très expressif sur
mesure fait en une ou deux heures que
l'on marchande modérément
c'est bien ici saint benoît ces retours
de la patte d'eph
on croyait katmandou jeu c'est fini le
nez en faites pas cela si jamais arrêté
jamais arrêter les années 70 sont restés
coincés sur mais en fait on boit en plus
même si c'est ça marche beaucoup avec le
twin c'est la première rentrée n'est pas
le tourisme mais les touristes sont
quand même tous un style particulier
chez pas les touristes d'ailleurs les
touristes une et mal même si c'était
très clair même si c'est les taux et
d'elips allons les ouailles dans les
cheveux longs la barbiche c'est vrai
c'est vrai c'est vrai c'est un peu mais
ne s'agit que deux années soixante dix
qui viennent ici viennent à même pas
avec la panoplie oui ça c'est beau ça
aussi il ya plus longtemps et il faut
pas croire que c'est un paradis de la
drogue qu'elle joue pas dur là c'est
complètement illégal mais vernement il
ya quelques années on a eu vraiment
marre ils ont mis tous les drogués
dehors ils ont bien fait et c'est vrai
que maintenant c'est devenu un pays très
très clean
il ya et si jamais quelqu'un se fait
prendre même en train de fumer du h il
va en prison et il est expulsé
immédiatement donc ça rigole plus du
tout avec sang séché
le paradis en a mis à part peut-être je
crois pendant la fête de shiva c'est ça
oui c'est vrai que les buzz de haschich
et voilà c'est vrai que les népalais
pour certaines coutumes religieuses ont
gardé se sont regardés le droit de fumer
du haschich mais normalement c'est
interdit mais également c'est interdit
même pour les méthodes tabassé et cet
endroit le plus commerçant peut-être de
katmandou oui c'est mystique à la fois
tu es assez baba cool et encore les
belles tenues les années 70 ce qu'on
aime bien et à la fois c'est ultra
moderne au népal en fait parce qu'on
peut avoir
bah tiens email interne à ça c'est bien
organisé pour ça ça c'est extrêmement
pratique et c'est le côté amusant du
n'est pas sexy à la fois le moyen-âge et
en même temps c'est l'an 2000 parce qu'à
tous les coins de rue c'est vrai qu'on
peut envoyer des fax ou des emails ça
marche bien et à pallier d'âge c'est pas
trop cher no6 pas cher ça marche très
bien et pour les touristes c'est
vraiment génial de pouvoir pour une
communication locale envoyer des
nouvelles à l'autre bout du monde reste
et en plus c'est la boulangerie au
royaume héritage thamel c'est un grand
quartier est
c'est là où l'on la plupart des
touristes il ya des hôtels oui alors par
contre le problème il n'y a pas de
nombreux numéros donc pour trouver un
endroit bien ouais c'est l'endroit
exactement on va avoir un maiden
trekking vous montrer que même si on
arrive au népal et qu'on n'a pas grand
chose on peut tout trouver ici restée
tout ce qu'on veut les sacs à dos
accrochages et c'est les prix
occidentaux ou moins cher c'est quand
même assez cher parce que c'est des
choses qui viennent d'europe donc
forcément c'est pas ma ses chars par
rapport à tous les objets locaux qu'on
peut trouver ici qui sont fabriqués ici
qui valent dix fois moins cher qu'en
france mais et qui sont peut-être pas
mal an jusqu'à les vêtements on peut
trouver localement on peut trouver
localement oui absolument tout ce qu'il
faut pour monter en altitude
voilà au pied le change beaucoup de
jeunes sera énormément non en général on
a 10 roupies pour 1 franc
c'est à peu près là j'avais compté ça
donc il faut savoir que la vie et coûte
à peu près 10 fois moins cher ici qu'en
france la proportion
oui donc c'est comme très très très
intéressant ça peut être un peu mythique
la science fait un petit bandana de mont
everest
pour partir en trek et qu'est-ce qu'il
faut prévoit en fait qu'est ce qu'il
faut surtout pas oublier un peu des
affaires chaudes pour le soir oui alors
la semaine c'est la fin des risques
caractérise le népal c'est les
différences d'amplitude thermique c'est
à dire que dans la journée il fait très
très chaud
parce que le soleil tape on est quand
même au niveau des canaries ici donc on
est très bas même si on est en altitude
le soleil tape très fort et
le problème c'est que dès qu'on monte à
céret et que le soleil se cache et fait
très froid donc on passe de températures
qui vont de 25 à 30 degrés facilement
dans la journée à zéro voire des
températures négatives le soir et delmi
quoi donc il faut bien se protéger la
peau et et prévoir des choses assez
chaude
nous allons à dili bazar à l'opposé de
la ville
donc là on est passé à l'est de
katmandou dans un quartier qui
s'appellera dillies bazar be bad
on a mis un peu de temps pour traverser
parfois le problème à katmandou s'ils
sont les embouteillages sinon la ville
n'est pas très grande et tu nous a menés
là parce que moi j'avais envie de voir
quelque chose qui est très en vogue
aujourd'hui en europe rappelle le
pashmina ça remplace pèse que le
cachemire dans ce genre d'école et des
tos retraites douces et assez luxueuse
d'ailleurs mais c'est fabriqué
spécifiquement au népal plus fine et
plus douce et plus chaude que le
cachemire la laine de pashmina se trouve
sur une petite chèvre semi sauvage
vivant parmi les tribus nomades des
hauts plateaux du tibet occidentale et
du népal à quatre ou cinq mille mètres
d'altitude protéger des léopards des
neiges par des chiens féroces
elle se défend du froid en fabriquant
cette laine incomparable
particulièrement douce autour de son cou
les bergers la ramasse et la vendent
sans toujours connaître la nouvelle
vague de leurs précieuses collecte qui
sera tissé à la chaîne dans ces mini
ateliers des faubourgs de katmandou
historiquement ce sont les empereurs
moghols indien au xvième siècle qui
firent venir des artistes de perth pour
broder les châles de cette magnifique
laine de couleur en persan pasche
signifie laine un jour le sultan
d'égypte offrit un châle à bonaparte qui
le donne à joséphine elle lança une
première mode en europe qui renaît à
notre époque on la trouve à prix coûtant
chez ces petits fabricants
nous allons à pashupatinath le plus
important temple hindouiste du pays
pas chaud patate c'est bourré de sage sa
magnifique tombe là encore qui est près
de la rivière baghdatis et ça c'est ça
oui mais c'est un temple hindouiste
parce qu'en fait au népal il ya 70% à
peu près l'hindouisme et 25% de
bouddhistes suisse ce sont des temples
hindous hisse donc nous bien sûr on n'a
pas le droit d'y pénétrer
mais on peut quand même avoir un aperçu
de documents aux alentours et c'est donc
là où il ya les crémations en brûle les
morts sur la rivière baghdatis c'est un
rituel à nos listes c'est un rituel à
regarder les jolies couleurs là c'est
pour faire quoi c'est pour faire de
l'imprimerie non non ça c'est pour les
ti-cats pour offrir aux dieux c'est pour
les offrandes ya les départs tout c'est
toutes ces pierres gravées c'était des
prières et après ils en ont fait les
dessins très bien me payen pour les
touristes
les temples sont dédié à shiva dieu
destructeur et créateur du panthéon
hindouiste tout hindouiste fervent rêve
d'être incinérée sur les berges de la
rivière sacrée avant de se réincarner
alors les gars de crémation les stèles
en pierre où sont déposés les corps sont
presque toujours en combustion
c'est ce qu'on appelle les bols
chantants et c'est à katmandou ils sont
faits de sept métaux différents
c'est encore à savoir faire n'est pas
laid oui tout à fait et moi je suis sûr
que je ne saurais pas faire le chantre
le ch est pas le faire chanter la glisse
comme les vibrations dans le bras
je vais essayer doucement doucement
voilà
on
c'est joli tout est pourri ça sert à la
fête de holly oui ça aussi les couleurs
se barbouille de couleurs les enfants
voilà
mais le rouge c'est aussi pour les
hindous se mettre du rouge sur le front
c'est ça voilà c'est ce qu'on appelle la
ticad c'est le 3e c'est l'oeuvre de la
connaissance
c'est à dire que c'est et on peut sans
affublé quand on avait un certain grave
dans l'hindouisme c'est simplement non
non on importe qui même les enfants dont
on a le droit de porter une tique à
c'est le symbole de la connaissance
c'est le troisième qui te permet de voir
à travers les choses en fait un peu au
delà de l'apparence c'est un peu
l'essentiel est invisible
voilà exactement les yeux
antoine aubin des choix pour anomalies
chaudes et autant à katmandou je crois
qu'il ya des stades hôtels pas chers et
tout dans ta mail comme on a vu autant
là je crois que berra nous propose une
surprise c'est un palace complètement
caché à katmandou ya déjà des goûts
sublime porte c'est un aliment qui a
récupéré cet endroit
il avait récupéré toutes les fenêtres et
portes sur des maisons qui étaient en
train de s'écrouler ou sur des temples
donc tout a été fait complètement
suivant la tradition des war c'est tout
le travail des magnifiques sublimissime
un endroit pour se faire plaisir
incroyable va faire un petit tour
les jardins les papes le monde ses
parents à 16h dépenses de mouches ils
sont comestibles comme ça ils sont bons
comme ça oui ils sont pas encore très
sucré là il faut attendre encore trois
semaines un mois et après oui on est là
leur chair est blanche de born this way
à dix minutes à pied de pashupatinath le
palace de doigts rica est presque un
musée d'ailleurs vous connaissez
beaucoup d'hôtels où l'on flâne le nez
en l'air et les mains dans les poches
donc berrahma présenter une amie qui
habite à katmandou je vous présente
marie là elle habite à 80 nouvelles
depuis 20 ans ferme intention de mal
j'arrive dans les bonnes années en fait
j'ai falaise d'amont 76 par la route et
filles revenus et revenus
finalement resté oui sans doute jamais
pensé que j'allais toujours rester mais
je suis resté puis j'ai fini pas marié
avec un népalais et qui jettent une
ombre palais on connaît palais et là
alors tu nous emmène dans un endroit
tout nouveau où tu as pu élire domicile
pour un magasin et il ya un artisanat
toi auquel tu t'es principalement
intéressés bon oui c'est au papier
népalais
c'est vraiment quelque chose de très
intéressant parce que c'est un papier
par rapport aux dames ans il est assez
facile à faire
c'est très facile de faire les papiers
népalais et en plus il est très solide
les insectes ne l'attaquent pas comme
les autres c'est très bon pour les
archives ça peut même servir à
désaffecter une blessure est super a
donc c'est et il est vraiment répond je
vais dire on peut aussi le tonnes comme
montagne du tissu on trempe le papier
dedans et ça y est c'est un c'est
parfait sa part pas en morceaux donc ses
impôts est en plus plus je trouve des
idées plus il ya de choses à faire ses
arrêts à ses précédents on va voir le
papier faut déjà qu'on atteigne jusqu'à
la boutique parce que là c'est un
immense pas là c'est ça en réalité
c'était les écuries et les parties ou de
des domestiques qui était attaché à un
autre palais qui était avant là et qui a
disparu en grande partie et où le
propriétaire qui lui a perdu évidemment
tous à un moment donné où le roi a
repris le pouvoir fait un ramdam
pourquoi edf lui là il a eu ses rêves
d'enfance et
il a voulu refaire un
tout allait comme il avait rassemblé
c'est lumineux mais je pensais le papier
ça pourrait être que pour les journées
en fait j'utilise beaucoup pour la
lumière une chose est magnifique
maintenant j'ai commencé à faire des
stores carte bleue coudre ce papier peut
devenir comme du tissu on peut faire
c'est très très solide
l'endroit s'appelle baber malraux
visiteurs
c'est chic et sympathique marqué
d'influencé britannique et indiennes et
il y a un bon restaurant français
nous quittons katmandou pour cheat one
la sortie de la vallée est encombré
fréquemment empruntée par les routiers
au milieu desquels se faufile comme un
hallucinant yéti des collines une femme
revenant des champs
là on a coûté 4 manouche
des petits glissements de terrain dont k
pour bouter
alors opacité gatineau tôt
patience et longueur de temps font
clairement meilleur usage que rage au
népal se mettre en colère prend ici tout
son ridicule
cap au sud-ouest vers l'inde dans le
teraï tropicale pour partir découvrir la
savane du sous continent
nous empruntons la manne dragway qui
sillonnent le pays d'est en ouest
la navigation est simple seuls deux
grandes routes traverse le territoire
par de beaux paysages lumineux
matri katmandou pour le parc national de
chitwan qui est dans le terrain
c'est-à-dire ont su
l'asra disons la plus basse
népal en altitude
on était à 1300 mètres d'altitude à
katmandou
on va descendre à 81 cents mètres
d'altitude
on a privé
dans là c'est parfois souvent
embouteillées mais ici c'était une
autoroute pour l'empreinte pour aller à
six toiles en fait il ya très peu de
routes n'est pas les deux principales
routes elles sont assez bien entretenu
mais n'oubliez pas que les mâles ont
conduite à gauche
façon dont on n'est pas souvent que l'on
produit
il faut photo une voiture c'est avec un
chauffeur on n'a pas le droit de
produire
on n'est pas comme ça
la route est très belle analyse hier
quand on voit comme
c'est à dire que la plupart du temps en
double en montée sans visibilité
et donc d'avant trois camions vaut mieux
faire confiance
chauffeur ayant l'occurrence aux
présentes
bayard à jack lang elle qui est notre
chauffeur pour ce voyage
samedi
le sens du but
bonne idée
st
son père
on lira donc et android et des sons
ould daddah et d'android et des sons
sur la longue route qu'ils rencontrent
et un game un musicien traditionnel dont
la mélopée souriante me trotte encore
dans la tête
mais son prix
et
samedi
on verra doté d'un mât bardé dernier
descente
éradiquée dans le monde
les
oh
après sept heures de route nous arrivons
au parc royal de shit one en bousculant
un peu les habitudes
autant bonne tigerlogic on est arrivé
après une longue hautes loges dans le
parc national de chitwan y en a une
douzaine verra non et la plupart sont
installés sur des besoins endroit là on
est sur des endroits un peu marécageux
mais les petites maisons sur des pilotis
donc c'est bien ça évite d'être gagnée
par les scorpions et les petites bêtes
de la jungle il ya un peu des battles
animaux ici oui mais hier soir on a vu
un scorpion
on voulait pas effrayer mais moi il
était petits c'était un peu des
scorpions et puis de toute façon le die
c'est à dire le gardien de notre temps
est venu le récupérer il l'a pas tuée
parce que on est quand même dans un pays
à dos et on tue pas les animaux en
général il a jeté un peu plus loin et ce
matin s'installer tranquillement pour
voir les deux grecques et une jolie
ponton pour s'installer voir les
aigrettes
nous sommes sur la partie septentrionale
de l'immense plaine d'alluvions du gange
dans le terrain intérieur chaud et
subtropicales entre septembre et février
les journées sont tempérées autour de 25
degrés les nuits à peine fraîche et la
lumière éblouissante
ici règne un étrange milieu inondé
sauvage qui profite aux oiseaux aux
crocodiles et aux rhinocéros où l'homme
vit surélevée et fabrique ses murs en
torchis son toit en chaume au 19e siècle
la vallée de chitwan fut le terrain de
jeu des britanniques amateurs de safaris
le trophée revient à georges 5 et
edouard 7 qui en 1911 ont tué 39 tigres
en une dizaine de jours
cependant le statut de réserve de chasse
permis au parc de préserver les espèces
sauvages c'est plutôt l'éradication de
la malaria au dtt qui menace la faune en
amenuisant leur habitat naturel
j'ai bien sûr expliqué à la barre
pourquoi son prénom a provoqué mon fou
rire j'ai un peu vexé quand même alors
j'ai ensuite admis responsabilité d'un
bel effort très active
manifestement professionnels cornac
ok houeillès prise comme yes c'est
parfois on trouve des indices en train
de dormir à succès driver bas que ceux
qui se sentent protégés forcément
son voyage tigre ya de jouer parce qu'il
en a vu un et comme c'est la saison des
amours chez les tigres
il avait même un cook lécousse perche
dangereux mais encore un peu avisé peut
constituer mais aussi des jours alors
vraiment là les autres se branchent
croix vers a prouvé qu'on avait deux ris
donc toujours souverain
les éléphants sont tous apprivoiser
dressé en inde
habitué à cheminer parmi les hautes
herbes et les rivières avec quelques
humains secoué dans l'aude à cette
plateforme où l'on s'assoit à
califourchon sur hull approche des
farouches rhinocéros unicornes est
nettement facilitée et passionnante
en quittant shit one pour pokhara nous
sommes arrêtés par un drôle de péage un
éléphant mendiants et tout le monde fait
l'aumône 10 roupies pour présager d'un
bon voyage c'est une affaire
pas possible
le
et la route fut belle longuet sur jusqu
à pokhara ou à l'horizon se dessinent
les contreforts de l'himalaya
la neige et le ciel pur
les six heures du matin on est à chandra
cote là on a dormi en petits dortoirs
assez spartiate et s'il vous parle du
trek où on a retrouvé
demain c'est notre tir d'haruna d'art
c'est le chef des porteurs de celui qui
organise l'expédition quelle qu'elle
soit que ce soit un trek de dix jours où
une grande expédition une petite
expédition comme la nôtre namasté moi
c'était donc on va faire un petit rêve
déjà
chandra quote c'est un lieu sublimissime
pour se donner un peu d'eux envie de
marcher parce qu'on a une vue incroyable
sur les montagnes la chine de
l'annapurna un morceau de la loi qui
commence par la nature n'a sud et le sud
est avant tout nous expliquer nous
expliquait déjà ce qu'on va faire on va
marcher de trois jours so we are going
my way aujourd'hui nous allons en
guadeloupe sont bien deux maps région
dracott c'est ici en tant qu'hôte de ce
type il à 1900 m d'accord c'est presque
2000 mètres d'altitude
bon c'est pas c'est un peureux
l'enfantillage à côté de cause doit
vendre ou là aussi on va passer nuit un
dortoir et puis interne d'edf sur god
hand made le jour suivant nous allons un
landreau en passant par et ensuite on
retourne à ma maman il ya d'abord à
bruxelles d'imposer notre nuit et après
aux quarts
déjà devant le sida tue pas ouais ouais
voilà porteur nous en plus mais c'est
super
là on voit maintenant l'annapurna 4 au
bout de quelques heures de marche
c'est quand même assez satisfaisant 7525
m
salvio un vaste et ben c'est pas du
folklore que ça profite la famille ça
goûte les plats islam culot sur l'île
ok on a bien grimper on fait une petite
pause et portait en fait on est les a
rejoints il vont beaucoup plus vite que
nous malgré leur charge maximum 30 kg ce
qui est énorme
là ils ont pas 30 kg il a 56 ans les
cinémas droite n'aime pas les gros
malins gros a new way aux nationaux
tandis que 26 ans mais ok et le
troisième larron c'est lui qui à 34 ans
le trekking est l'apanage des népalais
même si le mot est déposée par la vague
de randonneurs tenté dans les années 70
encore par les récits pleins davanture
des himalayiste il y a les cimes
mais il ya surtout les marches d'
approche et tous les sentiers qui
utilisent chaque jour depuis toujours
les villageois pour se déplacer d'un
hameau à l'autre au népal au népal la
population et mongoloïde beaucoup de
pièces tard ou sur les sherpas et ici
sur les glisser les gones hockey toute
la vallée sont légaux partout aux grecs
c'est pas du tout mon bolide tout
indienne - wendel en fait on est passé
ça on est entre olala la chine le tibet
l'homme donc les gens sont très
différents mais c'est en effet remis en
fait dans toute la vallée sont des
fermiers peu importe la caste ils sont
presque tous fermés
la population du népal compte tellement
de groupes qu'il est difficile de les
résumer mais la mosaïque rien de la
rencontre des indes aux arrêts 1 de
l'inde avec les tibétains birman de
l'himalaya je sais pas ce qui suit le
rythme des grandes jupes longues
convient pas pour montrer ses jambes
ça qu'il est solide
à
on peut très bien partir en randonnée
seul du jour au lendemain
sinon il existe plus de 300 agences de
trekking qui peuvent judicieusement vous
proposer des itinéraires réservé l'éloge
du soir et vous présentez un honnête et
sympathique cyr d'art
son attrait
à des petites réparateur en pierre
dans ma confiance
inona pour now we trust
non seulement ce cap et de la rivière
maudit dupont la rivière maudit sans
doute béni par le match coûte cher que
l'on ne quitte pas des yeux et le trac
du cameroun s'est beaucoup de dénivelés
c'est pas difficile mais on a beaucoup
descendus maintenant on va beaucoup
remonté ce qui m'a beaucoup plu dans le
trech de caen drones
ce sont les sublimes paysages l'effort
progressif qui régénère vigoureusement
et le fait que l'on se sente un peu chez
soi en passant par tous et hameaux où
l'on s'affaire tranquillement aux tâches
quotidiennes
souvent les transports que seulement des
contrats sur les caravanes
à
ouais ça commence à recouvrir un peu là
haut
le macho de cherré 7059 m n'a jamais été
gravi car il est sacré est à bout
donc quand on fait un truc qui paraît
qu'il faut chanter paye pas et ça aide à
marcher c'est joyeux et il ya beaucoup
de fox home népalaise la fameuse qui
nous suit déjà depuis le début du voyage
c'est un hammam un marais salés
commencer à récolter le riz là bas
c'est fou un mini maison juste à côté
showman crec
ici c'est une famille de la caste des
fabricants qui peuvent toucher le métal
peut fabriquer le soutien le métal du
nord
d'accord ouais les outils des coupettes
et tout ça et là il s'en sert pour faire
en plus des dépôts en bois je sois
oh
biotope
ça s'appelle alors un peu la valette
tout ce qu'on a parcouru
or
m
une bonne journée de trek commence à 7h
du matin on déjeune alors vers 10 heures
et l'on arrive vers 3 4 heures de
l'après midi là où l'on va dormir avant
le froid du crépuscule et avant les
ampoules aux pieds à force de marcher ce
lot j'ai vraiment confortable aux
chaudes à laitages draps et électricité
les propriétaires sont même formés à la
cuisine qui tient au corps au réveil a
good book on a encore l'impression de
rêver toutes les cimes sont ensoleillées
d'ici on comprend pourquoi le macho
putsch et ray est surnommé queue de
poisson
j'essaie de montagne a vu les montagnes
on a encore une grande journée et les 10
pour la cuisine du matin koffi koffi est
ce que tu as milk of link up and just
plaques copiées de splash coca cola
black coffee mais chacun dans ce cinéma
revirement dans les cuisines matin on
saura si c'est la salle de petit
déjeuner dîner et on commande un pancake
ce yes par mac avec ses crèmes des
pancakes oui prenez là où donner des
crêpes avec du miel de la grande
spécialité du matin
à
aujourd'hui encore une grande dette
grecque on va jusqu'à lundi et là on
retrouve des petits chevaux qui vont
l'accompagner nous supporter un peu par
la suite du trek
on rigole toujours d'en bas
parent je tiens à dire que les chevaux
ne sont pas loin un super en dévoilant
de brooke comment souvenir pour vera qui
a fait un trait cache valley 6 1
ouais c'était cinq ans avec ces mêmes
petits chevaux pour magnifier les dix
jours à bagdad dans les cas c'est un peu
et c'était un peu un rêve de monter à
cheval ici bon voilà le deuxième monture
d'un pas très haut
tiens à les battre
allez de quoi être très content parce
que tous les gens du village s'est
surpris demande d'où ils viennent et les
chevaux ville de pokhara
les miels
une grande mais ça on va pas le mettre à
l'épreuve quand même
hé hé
bonne baignade
allez les petits chevaux de laxman sont
des mustangs des vrais cabré de montagne
robuste un peu résignés
waouh
drapier sais pas si j'arriverai à l'or
lui a précieusement ses chevaux de
bataille
nous formions une drôle de caravane vera
et moi à cheval le cir d'art et les
porter à pied à chacun son paquet j'ai
voulu alterner et puis j'ai enfin
compris que les mustangs effrayer un peu
nos compagnons de trek bien plus assurée
en marchant pour nous et pour le dernier
jour
c'était amusant de varier les plaisirs
qui condamne pouce pour katmandou et
savait que c'était que se termine cette
aventure asiatique au népal j'espère que
vous aurez aimer voyager avec nous
autant qu'on aurait aimé vous faire
partager notre voyage j'espère que vous
aurez mais découvrir l'esprit seventies
encore vivant à katmandou et la beauté
des montagnes himalayennes comme ça veut
nous le faire partager les népalais chao
à bientôt